ein pokémon karte kann sich irgend
jemand von euch daran erinnern das war
einmal pokémon card dem happy meal hatte
etwas glaubt netz willkommen beim ein
video im jahr leute das ist ein sehr
sehr spontanes video was er überhaupt
nicht aufwendig ist das weiß ich erst
mal selber aber es könnte trotzdem cool
werden eigentlich laufen heute was ganz
ganz anderes geplant
nur irgendwie war ich mit dem video
total unzufrieden das hatte ich schon so
halb fertig und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht wenn schon die chance besteht
dass jetzt auch zu machen wir vorerst
weggeschmissen wird machen wir das
einfach mal und zwar ganz echt witzig
werden ich bin selber aufgespannt in
dieser tüte hier die habe ich von meiner
mutter bekommen da sind noch so ungefähr
10 12 ganz alte macdonald happy meal
spielserie drin also damals als ich so
fünf sechs sieben acht neun jahre alt
war und mein handy mail bestellt habe
ich weiß nicht bestellt heutzutage auch
noch auf den happy meal gab es ja halt
mein spielzeug dabei und ein paar dieser
spielzeuge hatten wir noch da oben in
seiner tour drin
ich wusste dass auch nicht mehr aber war
anscheinend so sie sind auch schon total
zu gestalten ich suche gleich mal nach
einem datum hier drauf vielleicht ja
aber das sind halt also ich würd sagen
'ich packe die erst mal alle auf am
witzigsten ist das denkmal für die leute
die in einem ähnlichen alter sind wie
ich und sich dann halt einfach so zurück
erinnern können wie das damals so aus
sagt ich weiß noch es gab ja auch mal
diese ganz ganz alten togo teil da kommt
man so dran ziehen und dann wurde zur
musik abgespielt also das verbinde ich
somit hätten mit spielzeugen und
kartenspiel ist das hier antwort der
weihnachtsmann soll den wunschzettel für
das christkind mitnehmen mein
wunschzettel als ich habe früher immer
wunschzettel geschrieben hat ja jedes
kind eigentlich gemacht und dieser wird
anscheinend da haben meine eltern
anscheinend einen noch diesen
wunschzettel genommen und ich in diesem
korb gefallen hat ihm halt nicht finde
und er wird nicht vom christkind
abgeholt es gibt selbst
das ist ja voll krass dass ich so was
das ist so was von mir noch jetzt also
der wunsch staffel ist zehn jahre alt da
war ich neun fifa 2008 für die xbox den
neuen trainingsanzug von zwei neue
pokémon pakete einmal pokémon keeper und
ein normales kleines paket 10 fußball
steckt also die trassen ansprüche waren
das jetzt nicht mehr
eigentlich habe ich immer darauf
geschrieben so xbox playstation gameboy
nintendo okay darum soll es ja gar nicht
gehen deswegen habt ihr auch nicht auf
das video geklickt als wenn wir 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 sachen und ich würde
sagen wir fangen einfach mal mit diesem
teil hier an
ich such mal kurzen datum wo ich weiß
gar nicht ob ihn dafür drauf steht also
mir wurde gesagt die sachen sind
mindestens zehn jahre alt ich kann mich
auch nicht erinnern dass ich sonst
irgendwie großen auch spielzeuge
aufgebahrt wo ich schon so elf oder
zwölf war
also ich würde schon sagen so irgendwas
zwischen 10 und 15 jahren müsste das
altsein das merkt man auch wenn man das
anfangs ist es richtig war das hört sich
eigentlich an
aber es wird einfach irgendwie nicht
aufgemacht so wir schauen jetzt hier mal
rein
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier sein
soll
ich habe allerdings eine vermutung und
zwar denke ich dass es kein einzelteil
ist sondern dass das sonst etwa das war
ja früher öfter mal so also wenn wir
sagen kann wozu das gut sein soll
schreibe es in die kommentare ich habe
absolut keine ahnung geil so dass erst
einmal ausgepackt
damit wird sagen wir machen hier mit
weiter steht hier vielleicht ein datum
also es geht halt echt daneben wurden
daten dort aber so warte man hier ist
doch bestimmt zettel dabei jetzt kann
man das schon mal hinstellen und jetzt
wir haben hier als nächstes ein drachen
ok solche sachen gibt es heutzutage
glaube ich auch noch ab und zu und
drachen mit einem flügel hat man ja das
ding ist leider schrott ich weiß nicht
warum aber anscheinend gehen die sachen
nach zehn jahren auch mal kaputt oder
dass man sie überhaupt antwort das ist
ein toller drache stelle ich mir erst
mal in mein zimmer wo als ich weiß ganz
genau was das ist allemal doch nach oben
die diese gruppe kennen und zwar müsste
das schon madagaskar sein
mach doch was ob die leute das ist ein
augenschmaus ist auch kaputt eigentlich
sollte man das so aufdrehen können dann
dreht sich beides wie man gerade gesehen
hat nur ist funktioniert nicht mehr als
wenn man schon eine giraffe drachenclub
fällt auf was ich gerade mal sagen muss
wenn ich mir heute die spielzeuge ansehe
die ich komischerweise immer mit nach
hause liebe finde ich dass sie schon
echt besser also ja keine ahnung ihr
könnt ihr mal eure meinung in die
kommentare schreiben also die spielzeuge
früher waren irgendwie geil ich habe
dich du auch manchmal gesammelt bis sich
alle hatten gestoppt hier kann ich nicht
öffnet ja nichts besonderes ein tag
genau hieran kann ich mich auch noch
verhindern
wahrscheinlich hatte ich das doppelt
deswegen ist nicht der ort gelandet
hier haben wir sondern die noa und hier
müsst ihr jetzt irgendwas passieren aber
das ist so alt dass die batterie lässt
normalerweise konnte man nicht anmachen
und dann hat das irgendwas gemacht dann
kam sein es leuchtet noch aber
normalerweise kommt man da drin ist ein
dino habt ihr das gerät leuchten sehen
jetzt sieht man es ganz leicht leuchten
nach über zehn jahren funktioniert da
noch was
okay wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
dinge und das ist ebenfalls dann kenne
ich auch nicht irgendwo ja so als
nächstes haben wir hier
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das teilt
das kann gar nichts das hat mich richtig
aufgeregt wenn du irgendwas bekommen
hast was aber nichts konnte man da das
single stellen hat geguckt ok woran muss
ich jetzt drehen dass das und das
passiert es gab aber keinen knopf zu
drehen
[Musik]
ok also einige sachen haben wir jetzt
schon wir machen weiter mit diesem
großen hund hier schon seid echt wirkt
es nirgends und daten drauf steht doch
hier kann ich lese mir 2006 mcdonald's
also heute vor zwölf jahren konnte man
diesen hund bekommt was man auch
dazusagen muss früher waren das wirklich
alles irgendwelche sachen die aber in
keiner kooperation mit irgendwelchen
werbepartnern entstanden sind heute geht
man zu mcdonald einem happy meal sind
irgendwie die neuen figuren zu einem
kinofilm okay du scheiße wir haben ja
auch im kinofilm
aber es ist viel mehr werbung im spiel
heutzutage finde ich schon weiter
was dieses erotische bild und dingen das
teil ist von 2007 also guckt euch
einfach mal dieses ding an moment das
ist doch viel geiler als ebenso ein chat
dienste holzteil gibt so ein paar sachen
haben wir glaube ich noch das packt
jetzt gar nicht mehr aus dass auch noch
impfstoff dingen dann haben wir ein
pokemon karte kann sich irgend jemand
von euch daran erinnern dass man mal
pokémon tat dem happy meal hatte und ich
denke man guckt man leute das hier soll
feuer sein welches pokémon ist wir haben
die pokémon karte krah box boxee krapp
hanna und wir haben hier das pokémon wer
weiß wie das pokémon heißt schreibt es
in die kommentare mir fällt der name
nicht ein aber es kann nichts also alle
die die produkte von damals viel mehr
gefeiert haben als die heute logisch
auch weil mein kleiner war aber generell
wenn man das mal objektiv betrachtet die
geben wir jetzt mal daumen nach oben ich
finde das ist ja so einen unterschied
wenn ich heutzutage so ein kind dieses
moped gegeben dass man ihr einstecken
kann und dann hier auf den knopf drückt
und das kostet dann daraus wer hat wäre
das ist doch der absolute schritt so das
stelle ich mir erst mal auf mein zimmer
und dann haben wir hier noch zum schluss
viel gewinnen
oder wer ist es aber das ist hier kann
ich gut das war jetzt das letzte produkt
würde ich mal sagen
wir haben hier jetzt nachhaltig stoff
ding ist was ich jetzt da drin leute ich
bin wirklich positiv überrascht es war
so ein richtiger flashback gerade mal
und da sieht man mal wie schnell zehn
jahre umgehen können ich kann mich an
einige sachen davon noch erinnern an die
meisten zwar nicht aber am meisten
eigentlich an diese zeit ja was soll ich
sagen also ich bin mal gespannt wie
viele von euch sich noch an irgendwas
hiervon erinnern können schreibt auf
jeden fall in die kommentare wird mich
sehr interessieren checkt auf jeden fall
snitil in sydney ab lass nach oben da
und das war mal ein schnelles unboxing
von mcallen spielzeugen von vor über
zehn jahren die älteste waren zwölf
jahre her
wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen gibt
es noch nicht wieder rein und ja das
licht ist extrem scheiße hier